every now and then someone comes along  and changes every high-powered packers  have proven while they're at the top of  the NFC Cobb with the go-ahead score  daca me the dagger for the Giants but  finding them is easier said than done  the Giants have been lackluster in  two-minute drills all year can this be  the one that changes their season  Manning drops back his tackle fat and at  times it seems oh show timeouts left  could this be the last play of the game  the Giants need a touchdown until you  realize that there is an opportunity  in this very moment you discover its God  Odell Beckham jr. was you need the  playmaker in madden NFL 16